james patterson is one of the
best-selling authors
in history over 300 million copies of
his books have been sold
worldwide so yeah james patterson with
his
empire of books and movies and tv shows
knows a lot
about a lot but he doesn't know what
it's like to sit in the situation room
or have
access to the nuclear codes and lucky
for him
he knows a guy who does so in 2018
patterson teamed up with former
president bill clinton for their first
political thriller
the president is missing it immediately
shot to number one
on the new york times bestseller list
now patterson and clinton are out with
their second book
the president's daughter which tells the
story of a former president
whose daughter is kidnapped by terrorist
and joining me now
is james patterson thank you so much for
being here today
oh it's nice to talk to you
so how and why did you decide to partner
with president clinton on these books
it's such a cool partnership you have
i needed more torture you know uh
we've become nice friends uh and i miss
working with them
we have a good partnership and i think
the partnership is based on two things
one
we have we we respect one another and
secondly
we listen to one another and um you know
i mean it has become a friendship he
wouldn't give me a monopoly for
uh socialists for christmas as a
christmas present
and um you know and we thought we had
another different kind of a book the
first book
uh the president is missing is is about
a president who's in office
and um he uh he deals with cyber
security problems which obviously
it's really in the news right now but we
we dealt with it in a big way in the
book in 2018
the second book is the president who's
out of office
uh and um he deals
and it's a much more um oh it just deals
with it with the humanity of a president
making a president human
i mean it's it's such a cool thing to
think about
doing um a book like this with a former
president
what exactly is the process that you go
through when you're co-writing a book
with a former president do you
do you have meetings do you have zooms
it was the pandemic
uh i'm assuming a part of the process at
least
yeah no we um uh
with the outline we go back five six
seven times just
you know streamlining it making it
tighter uh
layering the characters so that they're
more interesting
um and then we'll just go back and forth
every week with pages uh he'll write
some i'll write some
uh what separates uh the president's
daughter
i think from from most thrillers is just
the authenticity that he brings to it
i mean a lot of writing we've had a lot
of blurbs and things and people just say
it's a freight train that the action
never stops
but i think the other piece of it is is
that it's just so authentic
i mean some of the things although it's
hard to say anything couldn't happen in
this day and age because everything
seems to be able to happen
but uh uh if such and such happened
the president can say okay here's how it
would happen here's what the secret
service would do
here's what what what i would be capable
of doing here's what i couldn't do
here's who i might reach out to for help
you know but you know you're not it's a
grow white house
sorry right exactly
but but it makes me think about one of
the things that i imagine
is difficult um even though you have a
former president politics in real life
right now
it's a little bit nuts right so how do
you make sure
to make a political thriller compelling
but also
try to keep it grounded in what could
potentially be reality
well i think it is very great it has to
be with with with
with clinton involved um but i
you know one of the things in both of
these books is
we we make sure that the president is a
good human being
uh and i think that's useful for people
i think people want it
i think no matter what people's politics
are left or right i think
most people agree that bine is a good
person you may disagree
with his policies you may think his
policies are great but but we've all
felt it was important to have a
president that
in in in the president's daughter where
people go
he's a good human being and then to
humanize
um and and what could be more
such a human thing that we can all
identify with which is
which is one of your loved ones in this
case a daughter uh
being in jeopardy and she is kidnapped
and he's in a position where he can help
to find her
uh and we would all if we if that was in
our power we would do that
we can all identify with that yeah a
horrifying i mean sure your parents
would go oh my god our little girl is
missing you know that's terrible
right and but so we all can we all can
feel them
so yeah the president's daughter in this
book mel is kidnapped
but she's also the hero right of the
story what was the idea
behind that character yeah she is the
hero
uh well i mean one of the things he does
which is great for me
and it i think it makes the books with
him better
than sometimes what i do on my own is he
keeps pushing and pushing and pushing to
make sure that the characters are
rounded
that they're complicated that there's
good things and bad things about them
and mel i i think the president and i
both agree that he's our
she's our favorite character in the book
just because of how she handles
adversity
um she's courageous but not in a
ridiculous way
she wants to survive uh and she does
sort of
incredibly uh heroic things along the
way
hopefully she'll survive i'm not going
to ruin the ending here but
uh but i i guarantee you there will be
some surprise some some twists and turns
that you won't expect
in in the president's daughter
do you get the idea that a former
president who has lived sort of the
real and unpredictable life of a
president where you wake up in the
morning and
you know you think you your schedule is
one thing but then you have to go to the
situation room
does that help in the process of
creating a political thriller
because he can pull on those moments
where it was
a crisis mode uh immediately at the at
the drop of a dime
yes yeah now absolutely he's been
through it it's there's nothing like it
he's been through it as a president he's
been through it as a as a parent
uh and and hillary the same way and
hillary you know hillary and i that
we've become friendly too and
and and she read the book and uh and and
approved which is which is good
there she is yeah hillary clinton yes
yeah
hillary clinton i worked for hillary
clinton so i i have a
i'm a little bit biased uh when it comes
to to
hillary clinton she is she is a very
warm and and compelling human
i agree you know just a quick story you
know because
we know them pretty well now the first
time we went out to dinner
my wife and i with with hillary and and
the president
bill and hillary i was a long dinner
and uh three or four times during the
meal we saw that they were holding hands
under the table
and that's not the way people perceive
them but they're wrong
and and one of the great things about
the president's daughter
is you really feel the humanity of this
president
and you feel the humanity of the former
first lady
and and and and the daughter as well uh
you you feel them you believe in them
you you want you want
this to have a a good ending the story
thank you so much for being here the
book is thank you the president's
daughter
james patterson it was a pleasure please
stay safe
i promise your watchers that they they
will not put this one down
it does move it is a freight train so
thank you nice
nice to talk to you i love books like
that
thank you you too
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching